be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on comic nation this is rob
and in an effort to make sense of time
runs out in an effort to basically give
you guys a solid understanding of the
basis behind time runs out what we're
going to do here is we're going to jump
in and explain the very early days of
earth-616 we're going to use a sort of
modified history as a combination of
what Marvel had already established as
well as what Jonathan Hickman had
modified as to more or less give us this
well-rounded origin the reason behind
this is because in earth-616 with
regards to time runs out and the end of
the Marvel multiverse or continuity
these elements are extremely important
for understanding what this all means of
how this all fits together so first
things first what we know is that is
somewhere along the line and the history
of Marvel Comics in general there is to
say all the universes that have ever
existed that the one above all came into
existence and we don't really know how
exactly this happened and in fact the
one above all in a lot of ways people
usually attribute to either being Jack
Kirby or Stan Lee with regards to the
advent of the Marvel Universe but the
fact remains that the one above all can
best be explained as a prime mover that
the one above all is the absolute power
and the absolute authority within the
realm of all universes that have ever
existed can ever exist or do currently
exist in the Marvel comics so if the one
above all is effectively God and the
Marvel Universe then the Living Tribunal
is the hand of God and what I mean by
that is a Living Tribunal because the
one above all is largely hands off The
Living Tribunal exists to carry out the
will of the one above all to ensure that
there's no imbalance in terms of the
cosmos that every universe maintains its
balance in terms of who's in power and
how the universe functions they here's
some really good examples during the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline one of the
most popular storylines both here on my
channel and in Marvel Universe proper
that was an event where by Thanos had
basically captured the infinity gems and
then placed him replace the gems on his
glove which basically made the glove and
Infinity Gauntlet of course anything can
really be Infinity Gauntlet but
nonetheless that was the basis behind
this story the motivation of Thanos
during this story was to gain absolute
power but to also impress mistress death
now when the Infinity Gauntlet event
happened and the cosmic entities came
together to appeal to the Living
Tribunal to stop Thanos The Living
Tribunal chose not to act and the reason
why according to the Living Tribunal was
because Thanos was simply just usurping
the role of eternity the highest ranking
member of the cosmic entities if
eternity was unable to maintain his
position as the absolute authority
within the confines of earth-616 then
this was just the natural order of
things eternity would be replaced by a
being who could now at the end of
Infinity Gauntlet when Adam warlock had
attained the Infinity Gauntlet proper we
found the Living Tribunal did choose to
step in and the reason why is because
where Thanos wanted to simply attain
absolute power
Thanos had an understanding of the
concepts of life and death he understood
what it meant to live and what it meant
to die Adam warlock did not have this
concept Adam warlock was a being that
was created but over the course of his
life he had demonstrated I guess in
multiple instances that he didn't really
understand the value of life and so Adam
warlock would have most likely led to
the ruin of the Marvel Universe or the
earth-616 universe proper without really
understanding what it was that he was
doing and so as a result the Living
Tribunal had forced Adam warlock to
disperse the Infinity Gauntlet and to
ensure the Infinity Gauntlet was never
brought back together again now of
course we saw the Infinity Gauntlet was
restored and there are various stories a
tie-in to that but we're not going to
get into it now
in terms of the origin of the earth-616
proper this origin story is given to us
in several ways there are several
stories that tell us what the origin is
but the story that I choose to use is
the story that was unfolded and Thor
issues number 169 through 170 and what
this does is it serves two purposes the
first purpose is to effectively give us
the origin of the earth-616 universe but
the other thing it does is it gives us
the origin of Galactus and so for those
of you guys who haven't seen my video
about Galactus I think you'll find this
portion of the video particularly
interesting what we know is that there
was a universe prior
or to the earth-616 universe and that as
that universe was beginning to come to
an end as it was facing its imminent
destruction a man named Galan was trying
to find a way to stop it
but ultimately he was unsuccessful and
so as that universe began to die the
conscious of the I guess consciousness
of the entire universe in the form of
that universes eternity and the Phoenix
force bonded themselves with Galan and
so when the earth-616 universe came into
existence as a result of the destruction
of the previous universe Galan was born
into the earth-616 universe as Galactus
and of course we know what the history
of Galactus he consumes worlds for
energy so on and so forth but that is
the origin story that I choose to follow
there are others so there are other
origin stories based on different events
different circumstances but again this
is the one that I've sort of referred
here now what we know we're I guess what
was established with regards to Warren
Ellis and the six issue limited series
knew Universal was the idea of the super
flow one of the questions a lot of
people had who had been reading Marvel
Comics for quite some time although it
really wasn't one of the biggest
questions they had was if a person uses
telepathy what happens do the thoughts
go directly into the minds of another
person or is there some form of medium
is there someplace those thoughts go
before they reach the person that was
what Warren Ellis answered with new
universal he created the idea of this
super flow the super flow is this
concept that exists and of course the
super flow exists in each universe that
is to say there is a super flow for
every universe but the super flow as
explained to us is this place where all
ideas all concepts originate from the
super flow is a place where people go to
when they dream whenever a person dreams
of the mobile universe and they have all
these different thoughts rambling
through their head that's the super flow
when a person uses telepathy and they
speak into the mind of another the
thoughts leave the mind of the person
performing telepathy they travel through
the super flow and they end up in the
mind of the person is having telepathy
performed on and so I don't know if that
makes a whole lot of sense I'm kind of
hoping it does but that's the entire
basis behind the super flow now after
the in I guess after the the creation or
the introduction of the earth-616
universe we saw the very first sentient
race to ever exist
the very first sentient race to ever
exist was a race called the builders now
we don't really have a particular name
for them aside from the builders as just
kind of how they referred to but again
because they were the very first race to
exist there came a point in their
evolution whereby they had reached their
peak they had reached the point at which
they considered what they were to become
I guess total perfection they were at
this point where they believed they
couldn't go any further and so their
goal was to effectively spread this
perfection
throughout all existence and so what the
builders did is in the SuperFlow itself
they basically established these sort of
communication devices think of them as
basically satellites more or less these
satellites all across the multiverse
will communicate with each other but
what will happen is that when any one
particular race inside a inside a
universe reaches a point whereby it's
ready to step into its next stage of
evolution these satellites will send out
a white I guess a white event or it'll
create a wide event and a white signal
the result is that individuals as part
of that race that's ready to step into
its next stage of evolution will be
given powers that nine of these
individuals will be chosen and there
will be the arbiters they will be the
people who will basically help this race
step into its next stage of evolution
kind of a gradual introduction to what
that race is capable of now nine people
I guess nine different powers are given
so to speak they represent nine facets
but for the sake of our discussion we're
only going to focus on two the first is
a night mask and the second is the star
brand now again these concepts had
existed in Marvel Comics long before
Jonathan Hickman's run but what Jonathan
Hickman did is he took these concepts
and he rolled them all in together and
he created this really in-depth and
really rich concept in the realm of
Marvel Comics now I hope this all makes
sense I hope this all kind of comes
together to give you an idea in terms of
where we stand right now but again we'll
focus on star brand and we'll focus on
night masks in their own separate videos
because they're going to be extremely
important as you get towards the close
of time runs out but again the purpose
of this video was just to give you guys
an idea of the basis behind the
a universe of where we stand with
everything so that we can get into time
runs out proper and you guys can have a
good foundation for what it is that
we're talking about with that being said
I'm going to go and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace